what zodiac sign is Michael B Jordan I'm
an aquarius February 9th what was
Michael B Jordan's first movie first
movie I was ever in this movie called
black and white long time ago uh first
real movie some real speaking roles
Hardball Paramount Pictures
um Brian Robbins Keanu Reeves it was
awesome who is Michael B Jordan's father
father is Michael Jordan Michael a
Jordan it's Michael B Jordan related to
Michael Jordan yeah technically I'm
related to Michael Jordan but not the
one I'm I'm sure they're talking about
right here does Michael Jordan play
basketball Michael B Jordan does play
basketball I haven't played ball in a
long time but uh yeah I used to be
pretty competitive at basketball did
Michael B Jordan get knocked out while
filming Creed wow these are the top
questions okay not technically not
knocked out but I definitely took a real
punch to the face it wasn't that fun